since the launch of chat GPT three
months after that we saw a real increase
in fishing attacks using much more
sophisticated language patterns um what
do we do to protect businesses consumers
so they trust this technology better
we're getting to the point where even
open source AI can pass uh human capture
tests so we might have to sort of just
charge some very tiny amount of money
um. 3 cents a day effectively to um deal
with the the onslaught of AI powered
Bots and that that is that is still a
growing problem but it will be I think
perhaps an insurmountable problem next
year and then you have to worry about
well manipulation of of um information
is making something seem very popular
when in fact it is not because it's
getting boosted by all these likes and
and and repost from um AI powered bonds
so that's why I sort of think somewhat
inevitably it leads to some small
payment in order to uh dramatically
increase the the cost of a bond